jetzt brennt es im hafen erneut flammen
lodern über der libanesischen hauptstadt
steht eine riesige rauchwolke nach
angaben der libanesischen armee hat ein
lager für motorenöl und autoreifen in
flammen gestanden lösch hubschrauber
unterstützten die kräfte am boden
anwohner sind aufgefordert die
umliegenden viertel zu verlassen viele
bewohner stehen ja noch immer unter dem
eindruck der explosionskatastrophe von
anfang august bei der doppel explosion
waren am vierten august mehr als 190
menschen getötet und mehr als 6500
weitere verletzt worden
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dir hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren